hello and welcome to this inaugural
spectator tv us
election special which will be running
regularly in the run-up to november the
3rd
and probably beyond the spectators us
edition is the new kid on the block and
we hope you subscribe to it
or will subscribe to it but our magazine
which is the oldest in the world has a
long and storied relationship
with america in the 19th century from
1859 to 1861 we were owned by americans
and we made substantial
commercial sacrifices in order to
support the north
in the civil war we were only major
british publication to do so
later president teddy roosevelt wrote
that he reads the spectator
every week and in 1903 he invited the
editor
and his wife to stay in the white house
the current editor is still waiting for
that invitation
in the first world war the spectator
played a crucial
role in briefing american journalists
and dignitaries on developments in
london
such as the high esteem of the spectator
that in 1967
someone borrowed it and created
something called the american spectator
but
we won't go there at the moment it's
fair to say
that the land of the free is in our dna
which is why we now produce a successful
us
website and a monthly edition for
american readers in fact we're offering
spectator
tv viewers 10 percent off a new
subscription
visit spectator dot u s forward slash
subscribe
and enter the promo code tv and we'll
even throw in a special
tumbler for you to drown your sorrows
from or to celebrate on election night
go to
spectator dot u s forward slash
subscribe
promo code tv in the next hour we're
going to be discussing the state of the
race that's a surprise
trump's foreign policy how big an
election issue will that be
the role of china in the election the
possibility perhaps the probability of a
contested election
and the significance of the debates as
part of our discussion we have our
spectator usa team freddie gray the
editor
of spectator usa amber ave
our washington editor and melissa chen
our new york editor so let's get to the
state
of the race on that election it's
thundering towards us because
the first tuesday of the month happens
early this november and labor day
happened late so it's quite a short
campaign in january before the covert
virus struck
donald trump seemed to be on course to
win re-election
boasting as much as he could about the
extraordinary success
of the job-creating u.s economy over the
last four years
then came the pandemic and it seemed
trump's lunk had run out now as we look
at the polls joe biden retains a strong
advantage but in key battleground states
most notably florida
donald trump does appear to be closing
the gap so let's
begin by talking to our expert guest
today we're very happy to welcome
charles libson he's professor emeritus
of political science in the university
of chicago
and he's a frequent contributor to the
spectator usa
so charles in the battleground rates
races
is the race actually narrowing
yes it is um it's important for
everybody to understand
that america votes uh by
state uh and each state has
the number of uh representatives
plus senators it has in
the capital and uh some states
like new york are predictably
democratic so the race always boils
down at least it has in the last um
number of elections it always boils down
to five or six or seven
uh so-called swing states which states
are swing states sometimes differ but
uh most people who look uh to
how trump could win boil it down to
states
like florida pennsylvania
perhaps ohio which now looks kind of
reliably
for trump but some other swing states
in the upper midwest michigan and so
forth and
in those states according to polls it is
narrowing all right now let me unpack
that a little bit
and let me go first to the national
polls
when i look at the national polls
they're not narrowing mr biden retains a
pretty consistent
leader between seven and eight points
but are we right to think that the
national polls are not what we should be
looking at
professor that's correct because
uh however large or small the victory is
in california
or new york is not going to matter to
whether
uh trump can get to the 270
uh electoral votes that he needs and in
the last couple of elections because of
large
democratic margins in predictably
democratic states uh the
electoral college winner has not been
the winner of the popular vote
the problem with polling
is uh several fold
one is do you get a truly random sample
of the people let's say in ohio it
doesn't matter
uh now whether you're polling california
except for local elections there but are
you getting a random sample and are you
and that means are you getting enough
people in the key states
that's hard with cell phones and so
forth second
issue is there are so-called shy trump
voters who will simply not tell
a pollster they don't know who they're
going to vote for
and the third problem is it's
hard to predict who
assuming you've got a random sample
assuming people are telling you the
truth
it's still hard to tell who's going to
show up
at the polls and vote there's an
enthusiasm gap
but there's also a questions
as to whether subgroups
african-americans
hispanics jews name your subgroup
how large a group will be voting this
time
and that's why even in a
well-conducted uh poll
there is still an element of art in it
right amber let me bring you in here are
is the trump campaign sure that things
are narrowing in the battleground states
because
when i looked at real clear politics of
course being a great website to catch
up on these things there was certainly a
narrowing
taken place but the most recent polls
uh in the battleground states suggest
that perhaps that narrowing has either
stopped or slowed down
right you when you look at these uh
battleground staples what really
happened was that biden had a really
significant lead
in june july and then early august so
what really happened was the polls
returned to where they were
in march and april really before the
effects of the coronavirus pandemic
and the riots really set in but what the
trump campaign is looking at is not is
the president ahead is he tied in these
states
they just need him to be four or five
points behind joe biden really for the
reasons that charles mentioned
there is an enthusiasm gap that they see
there's this so-called secret trump
supporter that's never going to answer
truthfully in a poll like that so they
feel that because of the way the polls
were in 2016 where pretty much every
major pollster had hillary running away
with the election
as long as trump is within really even
just outside of the margin of error
they feel confident that that's going to
translate to a victory on election day
melissa we've seen uh quite incredible
urban unrest in various cities in
america
all around the black lives matter
movement
and what surprised me is how prolonged
it's been i mean i remember earlier
riots in some ways were worse
than going back to the 60s and the 70s
or even early 90s
but they didn't last for as long as this
you didn't have it 90 nights in a row
of protests going on in places like
portland or seattle
you would think this would play these
are democrat cities they've often got
left-wing
democrat mayors you would think this
would play
to mr trump as the law and order
president
but is it it should um i mean
trump has been you know sort of
advocating for
sending in the feds to control um to
control all the chaos
and in some ways i think i think it's
helping him
you know i think many cities especially
if you look at what's happening
in wisconsin and kenosha with the
riots over jacob lake you are starting
to see this
um sort of push back against um the
margins that that were slowly starting
to to open up for
biden wisconsin is looking more and more
you know favorable to trump but in the
latest poll in minnesota where
a lot of this started you would think
that maybe
this was one that the trump people
thought that hillary clinton held on to
it
this is one that maybe they could take
from the democrats there aren't many
states like that
but it doesn't seem to be playing that
strongly or with the people in minnesota
despite
a lot of the urban unrest minnesota has
been
democrat since 1972. so i think it's
it's been
wisconsin was more recently flipped to a
red state
so i i think that's a factor and also
the you know um
look at who you know the senators that
represent minnesota
and just kind of like the in general you
know
with uh minnesota being the the tinder
box that set off
um that that set off a lot of these
riots like it was the big one this this
year that i think
yeah that affected us freddie
you can see how the trump campaign will
play up the urban unrest and
uh some of the rather unpleasant scenes
that we can see on social media not
always
in mainstream media in america on the
other hand there is the president's
handling of covet for which he ain't
going to win any prizes
he's not alone in that but he certainly
isn't going to win any prizes so
he may have a plus on what's happening
on the streets of some major u.s cities
in the biggest story of our time he has
a minus
i think that's undeniable i think even
the most ardent
trump fan would not tell you that he had
a glorious pandemic
uh the press conferences when he was
doing daily briefings
on the crisis were a disaster
overall i'd say and i think although
it's it's not actually quite as big a
win
for the democrats as some of the
democrats are liking to make out
and i think a crucial factor here which
is not very much discussed
is that medicare generally is a
democratic win
uh in 2018 the democrats were able to
in the midterms the democrats were able
to talk about medicare
and a lot of people don't trust trump on
healthcare so they want a lot of points
on that
the thing about the covid pandemic is
that it's blown medicare out of the way
it's an issue
no one's really thinking about health
care specifically they're thinking about
the pandemic and the crisis
so what's what's a big win for the
democrats normally has been sort of
slightly muted or blunted by the
pandemic
charles let me come back to you and go
back to these crucial battleground
states and just talk about a couple of
them
uh you mentioned a key one is florida i
remember in 2016 as the results were
coming in
when when it looked like after all mr
trump was going to win florida
as he did in the end that suggested that
mrs clinton's hopes of the white house
were not the slam dunk her people had
thought it would be
can mr trump lose florida this time
and still win the white house
he can but it's unlikely that
he could win the white house if he loses
florida
um and uh you
everybody who um looks at the overall
race
looks at how you put together this
number of states and
uh going back to the issue that you had
talked about
before um the
the um one of the problems
the the trump campaign has had a problem
there's no question
uh with covin as freddie says and they
get a boost
from the issue of uh
uh unrest urban unrest
but i wanna um go back and
point out that there's a big difference
between
unrest in a small midwestern city like
kenosha and unrest in portland
when west coast cities portland seattle
um san francisco
uh have riots or unrest
a lot of the rest of the country views
those
as very distinct and not related to them
but when they happen in a city like
kenosha
um they seem to be coming for us
middle america middle america the other
issue
that uh freddie uh pointed to
and i i'd like to underscore that how
right he is
is that the more an issue rises
other issues by definition have to
recede a bit
and trump's strongest issue is actually
the economy
and voters vote prospectively
they look forward not
so much backward and the
issue is going to be who is best suited
to restore economic growth we were
in just a great situation before the
pandemic yet
and the more trump emphasizes other
issues
including law and order which is kind of
on his side
the more it downplays the biggest
positive issue for him which is the
economy
and the fact that he is a kind of
undisciplined
campaigner he talks about anything
that's on his mind
means that it's very hard to get that
message out
joe biden is disciplined in the sense
that they've
kept him out of public sight we don't
know who this guy
is he's been around for 47 plus
years since he hit puberty but
there's a real question as to whether or
not he's the same guy he used to be
not just on issues but whether he's kind
of all there
and all of these issues are playing in
states like florida
pennsylvania wisconsin
michigan which are states trump must
win if he's to win the white house
i think you've just told us that mr
biden didn't hit pubertry until he was
about 430
um but i won't dwell on that
we'll move on let's go on to foreign
policy he was first elected his voice
hadn't changed
i'll take your word for that i thought
that's because he came from scranton but
never mind
foreign policy yesterday was another
extraordinary day in washington as
israel
the united arab emirates and bahrain two
gulf states
they all signed on to the abraham
accords a significant name
abraham promising a normalization of
relations between these states
and a commitment to lasting peace in the
middle east
other states are expected to follow oman
perhaps kuwait
the big one most of all at some stage
saudi arabia
uae and bahrain would not have done this
if they didn't have the approval
of saudi arabia in the first place
donald trump's never even given much
credit in the sphere of international
relations at times
he seemed to be all over the place but
for the uae and bahrain
to recognize israel to begin
relations with israel economic relations
flights between them
cultural exchanges and so on is a quite
historic development and although
foreign policy doesn't
often play big in campaigns this is
something of an achievement though it's
been done without
the palestinians freddie will this make
a difference in the election is it an
issue
is it a a plus for mr trump i don't
think it's quite as big a plus
as a lot of non-americans might think it
is however what it does tap into
is this sense that the media just will
not give trump fair treatment
because this was a significant
development it was a historic
achievement in many ways and all you got
uh
again uh from most mainstream media
channels was sort of
sniping and sneering at it and i think
americans increasingly find themselves
frustrated watching the news and seeing
a very obvious bias against trump on the
international stage and from foreign
media
and i think that plays in his favor and
it motivates
americans to regard trump in a favorable
manner
charles what do you make of it uh
freddie has nailed it correctly but i
i would add one other important point
um maybe two actually one is that trump
has gotten american troops out of
places where lots of americans can be
killed
that's a plus so a lot of people
thought it looked like isolationism
which would be something that a lot of
americans might not support
they think america should play a role in
the world
but if it's playing a role in the world
by putting less of our
young men and women into harm's way
that's a real plus
the second thing is that although joe
biden
has a lot of experience in foreign
policy
he's mostly made bad decisions and
he opposed for example uh the
killing of osama bin laden he when
when obama took that decision obama uh
biden was on the wrong side of it
he took um he was opposed to the killing
of solimani or he talked about it
afterwards and i think
that the biggest issue that hurts him is
that
he's very vulnerable on china but
that i think to most americans is a
corruption issue for biden
i also want to endorse freddie gray's
excellent point that americans
do not vote on foreign policy for the
most part
this isn't an issue like brexit that
dominates the landscape this is an issue
that is less important than the health
care
issue that uh that melissa and
uh amber have uh talked about this is
less
important than economic recovery uh
is there are geopolitical forces at work
here which
will not necessarily be a factor in the
election among ordinary americans i mean
it is clear
that the gulf states particularly the
two that have now signed the uae and
bahrain
they now see they have a common enemy uh
in iran and israel is their ally
israel sees iran as the biggest threat
to the region
the sunni arabs see iran is the biggest
threat uh
to to the region and they the the gulf
states
soon to be followed as i say i think by
others have decided
that the common enemy of iran
is a reason for making common cause with
israel
even if it doesn't does nothing for the
palestinians even because they're not
part of this indeed they've been
demonstrating uh against it they're not
in there they may be at some stage in
the future
but they're not at the moment because
they're more worried about iran
than any kind of resolution of the
palestinian issue that's just a hard
reap politic about it but amber i would
suggest although
you know that may be over the heads of
most american voters except those who
form
follow foreign policy americans know
that the middle east has been a cauldron
it's been a
graveyard for american forces it's been
a problem
it's created embargoes there will surely
be some sense even at the most general
level that hey
getting israel and these arab countries
together
that's something of an achievement i
would certainly say that one of the
major shifts in american foreign policy
or i should say foreign policy in the
minds of americans over the past
um 20 years is that they felt that the
aftermath of 9 11 was such a huge
blunder
there was so much cohesion among the
american people initially with the
decision to go into iraq and afghanistan
and that
sentiment faded so quickly because of
the fact that we didn't really seem like
we were there to have a victory but
really just to have
an everlasting presence that went on
forever
now the americans are looking at the
middle east as a region where they never
thought that there would be peace the
middle east was
considered to be a place that would have
conflict for the end of days
and so for them to see these
achievements coming out of the trump
administration
will certainly be um not necessarily
something that's going to decide their
vote but i think it will be in the back
of the minds of some americans and i
want to hit on another point
that charles mentioned with the
withdrawing of troops more generally
from places like syria and afghanistan
um military families do tend to vote
republican but i think this will be an
even bigger win for them because
um in working class families in military
families
a lot of young men don't have any other
choice than to join the military so if
they're
looking at who they're going to vote for
they know that this is their only option
the idea that they would not be sent
into a place where they could
potentially be maimed or killed is going
to be
a huge benefit to them and certainly
something that those families will
have in their minds on election day
melissa
amber and melissa a question uh that
really follows up which is about the
media coverage
we were just i think quite accurately
told
that these stories are just not getting
much play
do you think that that will mean that
the issue itself
that uh amber just laid out so nicely
doesn't resonate very much melissa i
mean i read the washington post
yesterday
one of the columnists saying hey this is
no big deal this is nothing really
what do you think really in the new york
times
this is a framing issue um the other the
other framing
the other framing game that they're
playing is the what about is in game
which is what about palestine
or what about you know this country
anyway
so who cares about the key steel um and
in many ways
it you know freddie didn't hit the nail
when he said that a lot of people are
waking up to the fact that
this seems to be a bias issue or a
coverage
issue where where where you know why
isn't the the media giving
the trump administration any credit had
this happened under any other
administration
you would imagine that it would be
signal as a huge accomplishment
well i'm probably with charles here i'm
old enough to remember the camp david of
course
and that that led the net with jimmy
carter
and arafat and the prime minister of
israel that led the network news every
night for a week charles
i i did a post on this yesterday on
facebook
that juxtaposed i'll say i'll send it to
you andrew
that juxtaposed the front page of the
new york times
on the day of those accords
every single story including the banner
was about them yesterday
if you looked at the website every
single story was about something else
they literally didn't touch on it
and cnn went one step
better they had a picture
of the white house grounds as this
historic accord
is being signed and said people aren't
wearing masks and there's not enough
social
distancing very i mean
you you couldn't you couldn't make it up
i said it says if world news
was being
reported by seventh grade hall monitors
that may be unkind to seventh grade home
monitors
you never know amber just final question
for you on this uh
do you want to give any credit to jared
kushner
he deserves a lot of credit and it's it
is difficult for me to say that because
i've been very critical of him on
domestic violence yeah particularly
immigration exactly
you said he was a kind of machiavelli
out of his depth in the spectator
magazine
that is true i have given him a lot of
tough words on
particularly the immigration issue i i
did feel he's subverting the trump
agenda a little bit but he deserves a
lot of credit
for his work brokering piece in the
middle east and look the media said it
couldn't be done
if you look back on the washington post
cnn new york times twitter accounts back
in 2019 some of their reporters
were mocking jared kushner and the idea
that he would be able to broker a deal
in the region
but clearly his family history his
close relationship with the netanyahu's
really paid off here
and he should um be getting credit
absolutely and the timing is right too
because they see this foreign
this common enemy that any of that help
mr kushner if he has played a role
but when they when they see
former enemies come together to face a
far bigger threat as they see it in
in iran we're going to stick with
foreign policy uh
everyone agrees it doesn't play that
huge apart normally in american
elections but china
has been a huge issue for some time
uh and it is probably a more pressing
foreign policy subject
than the middle east in this election
particularly as china has emerged as a
rival superpower
to the united states now donald trump
has made a strategic
confrontation with china one of his
administration's top priorities he
slapped tariffs on
beijing started trade wars pressured
other countries
to remove hawaii 5g from their
communications
infrastructure he's robustly attacked
beijing
for failing to stop the spread of what
he is called
the china virus melissa
how big do you think is china as a
foreign policy issue
in this election um
china itself is an issue because of the
coronal virus i think the coronavirus
pandemic brought that to the forefront
of the election um still you know second
third probably to to the economy and and
just coronavirus itself in the handling
of this pandemic
but you know for years um
the trump administration's approach to
china really
is a very sharp departure from previous
decades of engagement
um and and i think that
the american public has has kind of
waken up to that
um you know especially with the current
virus bringing into sharp focus the fact
that
our industrial supply chains on medical
supply chains were
for the longest time um you know just
completely embedded
there and therefore we were dependent on
a geopolitical
rival just to get important supplies
that we need
so you know before it seemed like an
abstract thing maybe it only affected
the farmers or people
for who who were in the industries that
trump slapped tariffs on
uh but now this was seen as a national
security issue for the first time
so i think it's there in the public
consciousness but
um you know whether or not this is
something that
is front and center uh to the to the
as people go into the voting booth
that's that's you know that
that's not clear to me how big it i
would put mr biden to the side for a
moment because he said a particular
attitude towards
china but in terms of the two parties
how much does
china really divide them now there's no
question mr
as you say mr trump's tougher line was a
departure from the obama years and
from what had gone before but then
perhaps encouraged by the the the covert
virus backdrop
it seemed to me that there was a new
consensus emerging in washington
that everybody wanted to be tough with
china even
the left of the democratic party wanted
to be tough with
china as well in fact there was a kind
of arms race
i'm going to be tougher than you on
china so does it my i guess my
point or question to you know this is
does it
differentiate the two parties enough now
it still does because um the well the
rep i think gallup had a poll in july
and
uh you know it basically showed that
republicans were
at 83 percent were more you know more
likely to
view china unfavorably than the democrat
68 percent
uh so there was still a partisan focus
here but the other issue is also
about russia so uh you know they they
have asked for i don't know decades now
which country represents more of a
threat to the united states and it's
in cycling between you know it's usually
it has been russia in the last few years
um but right now china has kind of just
slightly
you know eeked out uh on on russia in
terms of that
in terms of americans and how they see
uh foreign countries
as a threat so you know i there is
clearly a by
a partisan divide here uh china trump
said china
16 times in his rnc acceptance speech
um i think joe biden had only said it
once and in fact
dnc's four days extravaganza
it was really only one candidate that
said china and it was joe biden it was
just once
so you know it's it's pretty clear that
part of the focus
is is very different on on both sides um
what direction has a biden has a
corruption problem there
too doesn't he melissa well yes why is
that
well hunter biden especially um
has been involved in some deals that are
you know very um uh
shady and and china
yes and had it been on the other side um
you know i'm pretty sure the the press
would be all over this
um biden has also been in congress for
the last 40 years which has seen this
appeasement policy towards china
uh ever since uh you know
wto um so you know what direction
u.s foreign policy will take over the
next four years is
definitely dependent on which political
party is going to be in power
charles the american polls may not yet
have caught up with
this but there is there's no question
china is a far bigger threat to america
than russia
i mean russia zakaria has got a strong
military russia and has a huge nuclear
power
it's got a gdp smaller than italy's it's
a declining fossil fuel power
it's basically a regional power china is
a superpower in technology
and military it's got a global reach
my question to you about given the
importance of china to the future of the
united states and the 2020s is
there although a number as i see it a
number of democrats have kind of caught
up and are taking
a strong anti-chinese stance too
that's not been mr biden's record even
earlier this year he was telling us
hey china is not not really a threat to
the united states we shouldn't be
worried about it that's a problem for
him if not for the democrat party
charles it's a problem for him
it's also a problem that we need a
stronger
navy and a military buildup to confront
a rising
threat that's a problem for all
democrats
but i want to go back to the point that
melissa made
that many americans you see
i see we all see that
china is a much bigger geopolitical
threat
but the democrats have emphasized russia
at least throughout the the trump
presidency
and they say that trump has downplayed
the russian
threat because of his own corrupt
relationship of some sort to
uh to vladimir putin
so the fact that americans are kind of
confused as to where the threat
is the fact that the media has played up
this russia collusion hoax for four
years and
really hasn't withdrawn from that
position
and the fact that americans generally
speaking
don't vote on foreign policy unless
we're in the midst of a
war in which the case they vote against
the war
means that i think all of this issue on
china is largely an economic
issue there is the the medical
supply line issue but the fact that uh
for trump the issue for china that
really plays
is china has been stealing our
manufacturing jobs
that's a big deal and it resonates with
the fact
that biden voted for a lot
of these old trade deals
including the deal with mexico and
canada
nafta that make him vulnerable
in these uh swing states of the upper
midwest
which have a lot of manufacturing jobs
so that would be
ohio michigan wisconsin
minnesota those kinds of states
are real question marks pennsylvania
for biden because of
china stealing the jobs as trump would
put it
and mexico stealing the jobs that's
that's the way i see that issue amber
doesn't the trump campaign need to make
more of china i mean charles makes a
good point that the
the media narrative the media consensus
is all about the threat of russia
russia not as a military threat so much
we're interfering in the american
elections
trump's supposed this obscure or strange
relationship
with mr putin or whatever the whole
business of
whether the republicans complicit the
report that has bigged up russia
in america in american mines i would
suggest
more than it should be china is clearly
a far bigger more important geopolitical
threat to american jobs american
technology
american position in the south china sea
on the east asian rim shouldn't
miss mr trump be making more of that
it would be very smart for him to do so
because one of the reasons he won the
2016 election was because of his
um sort of novel approach to trade deals
where he did take a more protectionist
stance
as opposed to the free trade liberalism
that's been really
um sucking up the american political
space for the past
30 40 years so the idea that he would go
into this election not talking about
that would be a huge mistake and in fact
he's already seated some ground to the
biden campaign there
for example the president had a buy
american eo that was drafted up for him
in part by peter navarro as trade
advisor which would require
the u.s government to purchase things
like medical supplies that were made in
the united states as opposed to shipping
them in from china which would address
that um that reshoring issue that
melissa touched on
and he hasn't signed that eo yet and
meanwhile biden his campaign
has used the buy american language in
order to market his
own trade policy so he's been able to
really copy
the trump administration and co-op that
type of language which is
absolutely a winner for working class
americans so if trump's going to take
that issue back then he
he absolutely should be campaigning on
this a lot harder than he is
right final word to you on this freddy
well i would say it is actually a weak
point for trump in some ways because
he has always tried to play a double
game with china he talks tough
he slaps terrorists down uh but he's
always been
angling for this big trade deal
breakthrough with zing ping
and i think therefore the biggen
campaign early on
realized that this was a weakness for
trump and they did adverts attacking him
for playing this double game with china
but then typically of uh the democrats
sort of political correctness crept in
and they started to worry that they were
being cynophobic and so they withdrew
from that approach quite quickly okay we
shall see what happens you're watching
spectator
tv this is our inaugural u.s election
special
you can subscribe to the spectator at
spectator.us
forward slash subscribe you even get a
discount if you enter the promo code
tv a contested election
we had one in the year 2000 the year of
the hanging chads in florida
in 2016 it was a nasty election
uh one of the nastier in modern history
2020 looks like it could be even nastier
there's a growing concern around the
huge expected increase in mail-in voting
people deciding to post their votes
because of the pandemic
rather than go to a ballot station or
both
and that the result may not be decisive
and that that could produce a
serious problem of american democratic
legitimacy
both candidates already accusing each
other trying to cheat
mr trump says he'll have to see as to
whether he'll accept defeat
hillary clinton has told joe biden that
under no circumstances under
no circumstances should mr biden concede
on election night one
follower of american politics said to me
it is perfectly possible
since more of mr trump's voters will go
to the
the ballot booth than mr biden that mr
trump wins on the night
but that when mail votes are counted in
mr biden has won
by sunday then what happens there uh
what i would suggest charles
is a constitutional crisis what'd you
say
yes that would be the case and it would
be compounded
uh andrew by the fact that
there is very little confidence in any
american institution all the
institutions have been gutted out
over the past 30 plus years
if you look in the early 60s
more than 50 years ago and you asked the
question do you
trust the government meaning the u.s
government the answers were more than 70
percent of people
did today they trusted about as much as
they trust a used car
dealer but that is also true
for virtually every other american
institution with the exception of the
military
which but i mean if you think about
what's happened to the catholic church
worldwide where the pedophilia
crisis what's happened to the media
which
uh several of us have talked about about
its bias and so forth
and it's been known for a long time
that our election system is not accurate
enough
to give you the true winner of a very
close election
that means that an election ultimately
might have to be decided by the courts
but if you look at court decisions in
america and how they're reported now
and i think in a sense accurately
reported
if a decision is two to one by
judges let's say on an appellate court
the first thing i want to know the first
thing
freddie wants to know the first thing
amber or melissa want to know
is who appointed all three judges
and that was the case in that one you
look at and therefore
if the case ultimately goes up to the
u.s supreme court
uh where there is a conservative
majority but
uh it's not a stable majority you have a
chief justice a swing vote who could go
either way you you wouldn't have a
situation
i think like the one in the year 2000
where it was a close election
ultimately decided uh on the basis of
how to count votes in florida
by the u.s supreme court in the year
2000
and nobody went into the streets
it was accepted even by the side that
lost
as a legitimate outcome since then
there's been a decline and you can see
that
with trump or in the last election
saying he wouldn't necessarily accept
defeat
and now in this election you have
democrats
saying they wouldn't and in america
final point
traditionally votes that come in
late are corrupt votes that is they were
controlled by the political machine in
say chicago
and all of a sudden the candidate that
was winning
on election night loses two nights later
as votes are quote discovered somewhere
against that background if you have
votes coming in by mail and the votes
are unsecure
so we don't know for sure that every
vote was cast by a legitimate
voter who had a right to vote and we
don't quite know
who handled all those votes all the way
this is just going to be a potentially a
real mess i didn't realize i was going
to have to go look up again the old cook
county soft shoe shuffle
[Music]
that's my point uh and that's i remember
several graveyards used to vote in
cook county the old statement used to be
that you wanted to die
uh and be buried in chicago so you could
remain active in politics
indeed and then you could vote early and
vote often we'll come back to all of
that melissa
from what charles says unless
either mr biden or mr trump win by a
landslide
and at the moment that's not on the
cards for
either of them listening to charles
there
this is a potential to be a huge mess
and it's certainly it doesn't look
likely that it's on the cards unless
people really believe that there is
something
fundamentally wrong with polling and
that nothing from 2016 was corrected
um it's it's very likely you know that
it's
going to be a different winner
between the popular vote winner and the
electoral college winner
and um i am hearing you know thoughts on
the ground about people
saying they're afraid of all of this on
top of the riots that are ongoing
and what that could do to propel a
situation that's
even more violent um with with protests
so that's another issue that that you
know it's a possibility
well it sounds like it's certainly going
to be a dripping rose for lawyers on
both sides they're all going to be
tuned up with the most expensive lawyers
that money uh can buy ambulances
they have already done that but i saw
that they've hired
hundreds of lawyers
amber what is it about mailing ballots
um
why can't they be organized properly why
don't they
count them on the day with the other
votes why don't they count them in
advance and
keep the result quiet
why do they seem to want to make such a
mess of it
well i think the biggest issue is that
the united states simply has never seen
mail-in ballots done at this scale
before so the system is just not
prepared for it
there's of course the question of fraud
back in 2005 the
election commission chaired by jimmy
carter ran this study and found that
there was significant fraud among
absentee and mail-in ballots jimmy
carter later reversed on that decision
in may
of course when trump started talking
about potential for voter fraud because
jimmy carter could not be caught dead
agreeing with donald trump
but it is an issue in new york um in the
primary races
two really close congressional races
took
more than six weeks to get um a final
decision
and the other problem was that one of
the races was within 2000 votes
and yet there were 10 000 mail-in
ballots that were cast out for things
like minor clerical errors
or not having the proper postage so if
we scale that up
to a presidential election where we have
more mail-in ballots than ever coming
from all 50 u.s
states we can only imagine the fact
that the usps is going to be overwhelmed
that the election commissioners are
going to be overwhelmed
there's simply not enough time to
prepare
for the system undergoing male and
voting at this level and so that's going
to be the huge
issue come election day and why these
results are going to probably be delayed
for so long
it's important to recognize that every
state
conducts its own elections and has its
own
rules so you can't just say it's a
national
problem which it is and therefore it can
be corrected nationally
has to be corrected in north carolina
which is different from michigan
and so forth freddie when you look from
the outside of this it begins
as if a lot of the american electoral
process is simply not fit for purpose
you know you look at the way each state
draws its congressional boundaries
it's all gerrymandered to whoever
whichever
party is in charge of that state at that
time you look at uh
the mail-in votes how they're counted
how the rules are set by the individual
states america still has an electoral
college which most americans don't even
understand
uh either maybe not none of that
mattered so much in the past
it seems it could matter a hell of a lot
well i think the major issues
the major issue you've got is the is the
absolutely
ridiculous polarization that's happening
in america now
and for for a democracy like america to
work
you need some shared agreements and
shared values about how that democracy
will work
and that's just simply not happening at
the moment i mean a big
a a big way an interesting way of
looking at it is to look at what
the the various teams are various sides
are accusing
each other of pretty big conspiracy
theories
uh the democrats are convinced that
trump is trying to
use the postmaster general to suppress
votes that he will
use the military to try a coup uh if he
doesn't get the result he wants
and on the trumpis side you're hearing
people talk about a color revolution and
how
the democrats are trying to use the blm
riots
as a way of sort of as an uprising tool
to overwhelm the government and get
their way without
a democratic mandate right
so no big issues there at all freddie
the future of american democracy
therefore the future
perhaps of western democracy there's a
big american no file i'm
very worried actually a number of people
have said to me
who are huge always been huge supporters
of america have defended americans
against european
defended america against a lot of
europeans who have been anti-american
that they've never felt more worried
about the future of the united states uh
but in that cheery note let's uh move on
to the debates and our final subject for
tonight debates i think have become more
significant now because
the the pandemic has meant there hasn't
been a traditional campaign there
haven't been the mass rallies
uh and so on the wonderful pictures that
you get on uh
during an american television uh
campaign
uh the kickoff in cleveland i think it
is in september
the 29th for the first debate get the
popcorn
in for that it doesn't matter what time
zone you're in you have to watch that
live i certainly
will be things will get heated they may
also even get a little bit
incoherent as well given the two
candidates involved
when they get off their autocue on their
scripts
i want to put a point to all of you and
get you to react
it seems to me that debates
have been significant when they have
confirmed things
that people were already sensing so mr
dukakis
in his election he couldn't answer the
question about how he would feel
about if his wife was raped and murdered
would he still be against the death
penalty he didn't answer
that properly mr ford in 1976
saying that the
eastern europe was not under the soviet
jackboot when obviously
it was but in both occasions people were
already beginning to feel
that neither mr dakakis nor mr ford
really quite
had it and the debates confirmed that
that the debates on their own are not
necessarily game changers
now that was then this is now
can they be game changers charles
yes um all the emphasis
uh in the analysis that i've seen
is that it is the first debate that
really matters
but i would say in the last few years
the biggest issue that occurred in any
debate was in a primary debate when
the former governor of texas rick perry
said he wanted to eliminate three
congressional departments and could only
name
two i remember that and that confirmed
what most people thought
which was he was he didn't
have the intellectual capacity
for the job the issue for biden
is whether he has declined in a
cognitive
sense and indeed is healthy enough
to run the office of president now
expectations have been set pretty low if
he can
zip his pants up and show up on stage
the democrats and the media are going to
declare him a winner
but it's it's a very significant signal
that his campaign has been unwilling
to have him talk to anyone
without using a teleprompter whether he
can go
for a long debate without making
not an ordinary gaff not mixing up
iraq and iran like he did yesterday
which i think a lot of people would say
that's a kind of ordinary gap
but losing his train of thought or doing
something
that suggests that he's in the midst of
cognitive decline
that's his big risk trump
uh has suggest has subjected himself
to a lot of testing hard questions joe
biden has taken only the
the most softball questions if you were
a tree
what kind of tree would you be he's not
uh
potentially prepared for a hard debate
and i think the biggest
risk is will he make any mis
grievous errors in the three debates and
in particular
will he show up in the first debate
as capable of running the country
how do you see it melissa well
that was that interesting um uh
piece of news that popped up two days
ago when
trump basically said that he would be
willing to sit down
with uh joe rogan moderating a debate
between him and joe biden
and you know the the reason for that is
simply that
with with biden's numbers in the polls
if you know why
why why debate trump he doesn't want to
risk exactly what charles said
which is just the possibility of that
juxtaposition
and in a very long form debate like the
ones that
logan does that goes on for three four
hours this is something that you you
can't hide with
nice little sound bites or you know
cameras panning away it's not canned
it's
it's completely just freewheeling and
the truth will come out so
it makes every every sense to me that uh
joe biden's team has been completely
reticent on this matter they won't do
that
they simply won't they won't amber
let me bring you in as we come to the
end of our broadcast
i mean i don't thought both teams will
be worried about the debates and about
their man
but mr trump will kind of bluster his
way through as he usually does and
he sees it almost doesn't matter what he
says even if there's a gaffe
his base just gives him a get out of
jail card
but i'd have thought for the democrat
campaign people around biden
i mean they must this is their narrows
are going to be on tender hooks for this
if if there's several times he can't
finish a sentence
he's going to be a nightmare for them
well and remember the media
actually tried to give joe biden an out
if his campaign decided not to do the
debates there were several op-eds that
were run in the new york times
that suggested he should simply not do
them because they weren't going to be
fair and that he should
insist on several conditions not least
of which would have been a live debate
fact checker which for a multitude of
reasons i won't get into would be an
absolute disaster
uh and then even speaker pelosi
suggested that
uh joe biden should not get involved in
the debates with trump because again
they wouldn't be fair
for him so they had every opportunity in
the world to bow out but they
know that the perception of bowing out
even with the backing of the media would
be too much for the voters to bear
now the other issue is getting back to
mail and voting is how many people are
going to have already cast their ballots
by the time these debates conclude maybe
not by the first debate by but certainly
by the second and third i
i suspect a significant amount of
americans
will have already cast their ballots and
so that really
lessens the importance of the debates
even further
than they have been in past elections
what makes cleveland more important
uh than ever freddie if i was mr biden's
campaign manager i i would be hiding
behind the sofa during this debate
is not unable to watch uh in case
it all went pear-shaped uh is there any
chance
that they can find a way out of just not
doing the debates
i think i think it would be too
difficult
now to do it they may try it if biden is
being particularly doddery
in the days running up to the event but
i think as
as charles suggested that the standards
are so low that
the expectations are so low for biden
now
that really it's trump's to lose because
he's not actually that great a debater
he was good in the republican primaries
in 2016
but i mean overall clinton really
thrashed him i mean in the second debate
he scored some points but
overall he was he was really quite poor
so i wouldn't be surprised if
after the election open-minded obviously
partisans of biden are going to say he
won
but i wouldn't be surprised if
independence fell that hey biden wasn't
that bad
one thing i would say is that the
intellectual caliber
uh will be probably lower than any
presidential
debate we've ever had so this won't be
uh this won't be oxford union
that's for sure yeah it stands for the
oxford union aren't that high
but but lincoln douglas it ain't going
to be i think
it ain't on that listen thanks to the
home team
uh freddie amber melissa for joining us
uh
charles lipman thank you very much for
joining us too as our very special guest
thanks to all of you for joining and
watching this episode
the first episode of spectac spectator
tv
the us election special we'd love to
find out what you thought of it how we
could improve it we know there's plenty
of
room for improvement send your thoughts
to spectator
tv at spectator dot co dot uk
if you enjoyed it recommend the show to
your friends and family it'll be up
there on youtube
and if you enjoyed hearing from freddie
charles amber melissa
subscribe to the spectators us coverage
go to spectator
dot u s forward slash subscribe enter
that promo code
tv you can remember that you get 10
and a free tumblr i mean you'll be
wanting the show off my back neck if we
back next
if we go like this you might enjoy just
before i go the week in 60 minutes
it's our thursday night gathering of
spectator journalists in london
special guests for discussion on british
news european news international
appearance
signs surrounding coronavirus we've got
on the man who's led
the outlier program in sweden in our
next
program which i think will be of
interest not just to british or european
viewers but very much to american
one two you can see that on youtube as
well but for the moment
see you next time thanks for joining us
bye-bye
you